embrace your crazy ideas so as
entrepreneurs you come up with crazy
ideas it's kind of what we do if you're
not coming up with crazy ideas as an
entrepreneur I don't know if you are an
entrepreneur right we have this vision
for a greater world something that
doesn't exist we want to will something
in fruition that's what we do as
entrepreneurs and we come up with the
crazy ideas the challenge is though that
not all of us act on our crazy ideas you
get this crazy idea 1:00 in the morning
and then the next day you know you
promise yourself that night the next
thing gonna go and work on it and I'm
gonna go out and make something of it
and the next you wake up and it just it
doesn't happen you're not taking action
on it why is that and for me it comes
back to still to your environment you
have an environment that holds you where
you are that keeps you doing what you're
doing now and if you want to bust out
and create something bigger then you
have to break free of your environment
and the crazy idea is a moment of
boldness it's a moment of boldness where
for one one second or one hour you know
you're thinking man I could make this
crazy thing happen you suddenly believe
in yourself you believe you have the
resources the resourceful miss the
knowledge the experience the training
the perseverance the ability to actually
go out and do it and the important thing
in my mind at least is to go and
actually take some kind of action on it
don't wait till tomorrow don't write it
down don't tell yourself the next day
you're gonna do it because in reality
you're probably not gonna go and do it
when you were in that moment of boldness
you have to take some kind of action and
ideally commit to somebody else
and so the next time you can with some
crazy idea what I'd love for you to do
is write an email to somebody call
somebody up take somebody out to lunch
tweet somebody else commit to somebody
else to get the momentum started cause
it's so much easier to continue the
momentum the next day and the next week
that it is to start building it from
scratch from the beginning because you
never actually took any action the
second thing is also it's important to
apply your crazy these other people as
well and this is a bit of a touchy
subject one of the things that
that I've been trying to do more and
more is whenever I get a crazy idea for
somebody else I try to let them know and
it's touchy because they may not be open
to it right they may not want to make a
big crazy change in their life they may
be comfortable in their environment and
changing that is painful one of the
things that I'm really good at and one
of the things that I think is one of my
biggest strengths is I gotta believe in
people right it's my one word it's
believed and so I can't help but to
think when I see somebody that they
could be more than what they're
currently doing just something that I
see in everybody I see greatness in
everybody almost that I meet and and I
see them having abilities to be able to
do more than what they're doing right
now and sometimes that's all people need
a little kick start they need somebody
else to believe in them because they
don't believe in themselves and nobody
around them believes that they could do
more than what they're doing right now
and so even though my crazy ideas might
not be accepted might not be acted on I
still try to get myself into the habit
of when I come up with a crazy idea for
somebody else I let them know about it I
share it and I do it because the thing
that helped me was knowing that it's
coming from a good place it's coming
with good intention and it's never
attacking them and say you should be
doing this because you suck and you know
Harper and then for some negative reason
it's always coming from a place of love
and every single time it's been
appreciated it doesn't mean it's always
it's gonna get acted on to the means
they're actually gonna make a change in
their life but you now get to be the
person who is trying to be a force for
good in somebody's life and you know if
you're trying to build a new habit or
you're trying to change your environment
you know how painful of that that can be
and so you could be the one spark that
helps somebody start to take positive
action in their life so as much as
possible when I have a crazy idea for
somebody else I try to share it happened
to me this morning I was on a call with
somebody a group call and just I wasn't
feeling right about it I wasn't feeling
right about the advice that he was was
being given and I said hey listen Jim a
few minutes after to talk about it
because of a few ideas for you you may
not like him but I want to share it just
been bugging me
and so we stayed on for another half an
hour just chatting and me giving him my
ideas now again whether he uses them or
not you know he appreciate it enough to
stay on for longer than two minutes and
hopefully it sparks a positive change in
his life and I didn't want to
go on the rest of my day wandering oh
man I really wish I really wish I told
him what I was really thinking not to
tell him off right not like I should
have told him what I was thinking right
that's something else but I wish that I
would have told him what I was taking I
try to live my life without regret and
so that's part of it now so when you
have a crazy idea I want you to do
something in that immediate moment take
action towards its fulfillment in some
way ideally by committing to somebody
else
and then when you have crazy ideas for
other people and it's coming from a
place of love and a desire to see them
do more with their lives don't be afraid
to share it be sensitive about how you
share it but don't be afraid to share it
because I don't want you living with
regret for yourself - so how does this
relate to my book the other night I was
writing my book and it was 1:00 in the
morning and I was I was coming up with
an idea because I just did a word count
on my book and the initial deal that I
made with my publisher was they want a
50,000 words 50,000 words I can do that
I did a word count and I'm at a hundred
and twelve thousand words I had a
hundred and twelve thousand words
initially there supposed to be five
sections to the book I cut section four
and five out because I didn't have
enough time to go out and do all the
research would be required and those
could be future books and so we're down
to three sections which are all awesome
and it's one hundred and twelve thousand
words still and my thought was man I
don't want to lose half of my book and I
could use that a lot for bonus content
and surprises and stuff for you guys but
I thought maybe it'd be better to split
this thing up split it up into two or
three different books so we have the
awesome content and we can build
momentum into the next book into the
series and I pitched that to my
publisher and my agent at 1:00 in the
morning because that's when I can with a
crazy idea and ivanova what's gonna be
received you know I don't know if that's
something that they're gonna want to do
it wasn't what was in our contract and
you know I don't have as much experience
obviously in industry as they do so
we'll see what happens but that's where
I am at with the book I'm kind of
excited about that path but again we'll
see what direction we take the point
there being is though that it's a crazy
idea that I had one in the morning and
instead of sleeping on it and wait until
tomorrow to wake up and send that email
I sent it in the moment and we'll see
what happens don't live life with regret
embrace your crazy ideas now okay let's
get to the questions
first stop Tamara weeks this is
of Chapter six thanks a lot Evan will
you share something about it
so last week I was talking about how gr
eyes have a special surprise for me in
Chapter six I'm not ready to share no
not ready to share not ready to share
there's some it's gonna be exciting
there's gonna be lots to share timing
just isn't right quite yet I know I know
I'm setting you guys up it's not
intentional to make you guys what's the
word I'm struggling for the word I don't
know I love you guys there's a reason
for everything it's coming out soon I
will have details to share I promise
just hang tight with me a little bit
longer I have a question about the topic
on this video is it okay to hire
somebody good in the beginning of your
company but they aren't great because of
your budget then it is okay to hire a
great later on when your budget allows
so it's an interesting question and I
think also shows a limiting personal
belief and that you don't need to have a
lot of money to be able to hire great
people there is some correlation where
that you know having money helps but
money isn't the number one factor that
people want to go work at a company you
look at what makes people happy at a
company that they're working at money is
never the number one issue it's a number
one issue that employers interesting
enough it's number one thing that
employers think is important but it's
never the number one thing that
employees actually care about and so yes
people need to be able to survive and I
was suggesting you pay insanely low
wages but it doesn't have to be you
don't have to have a huge salary people
get great people on board what's way
more importance that people feel
recognized and that people feel like
you're on to something big they have
opportunities for growth for learning
they love your mission they love the
people they're helping you know why do
people go in volunteer organizations
they're not getting paid any money to do
it they do it because they want to give
back they want to help they want to
provide they want to feel like they're
nourishing their soul and there are
great people who become volunteers I
would say if you can't afford somebody
that's not the biggest hurdle it's gonna
be more about are you doing something
that people would want to join are you
doing something people want to volunteer
for right do you save or something
insanely powerful and impactful the
people can't wait to join your movement
we need to build on that'll help you
attract great people and as you can
afford to start to pay them and pay them
more that's great too but it's not the
most important thing Daniel you have to
do more periscopes at least for me you
were the man another shot of espresso
wake me up in the morning keeps me going
appreciate that Daniel yeah periscopes
been a funny one for me I've done a few
I had it in my morning routine when
there's extra a gap that I would do some
periscope the girl just haven't found
the lift for the buzz from it that I was
looking for and needed I might get back
into it it's one of those things that is
all my nice to have list and you know we
don't really get torn nice to have lists
that often so I might get back to it I'm
curious to know how many of you guys are
on periscope and use it you know for me
if I had an option between investing
into making a video for periscope or
invested into making a better video on
my youtube channel
I'd pick YouTube every day of the week I
make time for YouTube I'm suppose to be
writing my book I'm walking on the my
way to Whole Foods and I make time to
make this video happen where I don't
make the time for periscope because it's
just a nice to have you might see return
I might change my mind in a couple weeks
I don't know but for now it's not on my
list of priorities but I'm feeling the
love Thank You Daniel next up Elias
Elias is a longtime fan of the channel
of tons of comments all caps
I freaking passed all exams first time
in 3 years they said I couldn't do it my
own parents started doubting me after my
third try I freaking passed my load of
exams man thank you so much believe
nation Elias Congrats man feeling the
love I love it I love it thank you for
it's interesting that you know you
wanted to come to the YouTube channel to
share that news that makes you feel like
you guys really value the channel and
make an important part of your life that
you want to kind of share your big
announcements so that mean
a lot to me even though there's no
question there for me it really means a
lot that you would come here to want to
share that news and we believe in you
man
third time's a charm congratulations
good luck can't wait to see what you do
with the rest of your life in the years
ahead
I believe nation if you want to give
allies a shout-out and the congrats
leave it in the comments below and share
in the celebration Chloe
man this hit home for me once again I've
hit a hiring slump that I've had the
right people thought I had the right
people and was completely excited but
it's been three days and I haven't heard
from my partner I work at my business
every single day and I don't understand
when I told that it would take this much
time I don't know why they don't get it
feeling hopeless yet again forgot the
post a comment yesterday BT a53 this is
a super common problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs finding the right people
is tough and I think a big reason is
because you're hiring for skills ain't
not necessarily for values you want to
web design this you hire somebody who
looks like they have great web design
skills but they don't share the same
values as you do they don't like to work
hard they don't like the word wake up in
the morning and get to work they may not
believe in others they may not play nice
they may not you know whatever things
that you value deeply that's more
important than the skills that they have
and so I think too many people as
entrepreneurs and I get it you know
you're when you start you're doing so
many things you're wearing so many hats
you need somebody just to do that job to
take it off your plate and feels so good
where you can say huh
okay all about all of that stuff now I
don't have to deal with they can go to
that person and then it sucks when they
don't deliver right when they're not
performing where they're not giving you
the work that you need and so one to
make sure you're hiring people who have
the same values as you and make that
really important it should be in all
your job postings it should be up front
when you're talking to them not just
about how you're gonna sort up the work
but how you're going to actually run the
business right like what you care about
deeply and what you will and will not
accept in terms of bringing somebody on
I would say always start on a trial
basis first start if you're talking
bringing on a partner it's so easy to
jump in to jump into bed with somebody
who looks good on paper right it's easy
to get excited at the start of any
project you're all pumped up you all
have this vision and then once the work
starts
it's a crap starts that's when you see
what people are really made of and so
before bringing anybody on as a partner
I would say test them first try out a
small job or see how well you work
together seeing somebody that you can
imagine spending you know potentially
every day of your next five years of
your life with do you want to be with
this person and if not then move on and
find somebody else and then the third
point I would say is you need to have
standards I know it sucks that you lost
this person but they weren't the right
fit for you anyway and you need to have
high standards for yourself and the
people that you bring on board your team
it's mandatory if you want to build a
great business that has a great impact
you need great people who are great at
what they do who are aligned together
right if that doesn't happen if you have
people who aren't working the same
amount you have people who aren't great
at what they do or have ambitions to be
great at what they do then you're never
gonna build anything great and I think
it happens so much in terms of
partnerships we're almost always you
find somebody working harder than
somebody else life gets in the way
excuses get in the way something gets in
the way and it ends up leading to a
complicated situation it doesn't mean
you don't form partnerships these
partnerships can be great
I just think too many people rush into
partnerships too soon without knowing if
that person is gonna be a good fit for
them or not
are you walking in North York I am for
him I am walking towards young and
Shepard that's where I do my book riding
in the great city of Toronto and City
North York is a section of Toronto it's
where I call home so that's it proud
Torontonian it's getting cold here got
the hat on and excited to go right
venkat Evan thanks for the insight my
question is how to involve great people
and how can we surround myself with
great minds
you
a good fit for you but as soon as you
settle on that person then you stop
looking for somebody else right at least
most people to do most people do you
should and that happens a lot I think in
in the friends and the the people in
your circle good is the enemy of great
if things are just good enough you're
never gonna make a change so if your
friends the people are you who you're
around the people who are at your
business if they're just good then
they're good you know that justice fine
and you don't have any frustration to
want to make a change if they were bad
if they were terrible you know they were
abusive if they didn't get their job
done that they didn't support you it's a
lot easier to walk away from that the
people who are just good means that
you're never gonna actually go out and
seek somebody else was greater and so I
think that's the biggest thing don't
settle
keep searching if you keep searching
you'll eventually find it if you stop
the search then you'll never find it so
that's it for my book update I might
have an answer to my crazy idea by the
time next week rolls around we'll see
I'd love to know what you think I'd love
to know how you embrace your crazy ideas
leave it in the comments below and if
you have a question about my book your
book the book writing process anything
relating to books let me know in the
comments below and I'll do my best to
answer it for you
next week thank you guys for watching it
you need to believe and I'll see you
soon